vous lui parlez chokan kink elle saura
vous répondre et même des pieds et des
POS car Natacha hen est actuellement ici
ce qui se fait de mieux pour combattre
sur le tatami dans le style Kyoku dit de
l'ultime vérité plusieurs fois
championne de la Réunion championne de
France en 2000 vice championne cette
année 2001 elle s'ouvre désormais à
l'international dans cette discipline
qu'elle a découvert toute
jeune j'ai commencé le karaté à l' de 14
ans avec rondin pierre auparavant il
faisait un châauange et ça fait 12 ans
que je pratique le karaté chotokan donc
après quand il a changé de style donc il
est passé au kukushinkai donc ben j'ai
suivi son style et ben là maintenant ça
fait 3 ans que je je pratique donc je
fais maintenant les deux c'està-d
chotokan et Kuku Shinkai quelle est la
différence entre ces pratiques mais le
chotan en fait c'est plus de l'escrime
je veux dire c'est la touchette on
touche et puis c'est juste touch tandis
que le CH le Cushing c'est plus contact
au chos et c'est plus dur aussi c'est il
faut savoir encaisser quoi c'est c'est
le mot il faut savoir encaisser c'est au
chos ah oui c'est au chos je ve dire
pendant dans les compétitions en fait
pour pouvoir avoir le point il faut
mettre l'adversaire KO par terre et je
veux dire tant que tant que le la
personne n'est pas par terre ben on
continue le combat jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'épreuve de de balance pour déterminer
le le le gagnant ou la gagnante mais le
le le le sport enfin le la décision se
fait au koos alors comment faire pour
mettre un adversaire KO
avir ben la puissance en fait c'est des
techniques non c'est c'est des
techniques bien précises donc soit
des des mawashi gedan au niveau de du
tibia ou sinon des mawashi jodan à la
tête je veux dire pour pour mettre KO la
personne ou sinon bon ben au
plexus a des endroits vraiment
très très comment dirais-je très très
sensible mais sinon c'est très dur de
mettre quelqu'un au CH mais je dis à par
des techniques on y arrive mais je c'est
pas évident quoi il faut travailler et
surtout faut avoir beaucoup de
puissance moi c'est beaucoup les l kiic
moi c'est plus les les les techniques de
jambes que de point mais c'est c'est
alterné mais je suis beaucoup plus
puissante en en jambes qu'en qu'en point
combat peut durer combien de temps ah
ben tout dépend s' a égalité il y a
prolongation donc généralement c'est
c'est 2 minutes pour pour les filles euh
bon moi au championnat de France j'ai
fait j'ai fait trois hein TR fois 2
minutes est-ce qu'il y a des règles à
respecter oui en fait on n pas droit euh
point visage c'estàd toutes les
techniques euh que ce soit jambes ou ou
point on peut faire au niveau du corps
et point visage c'est interdit d' point
visage c'est interdit mais par contre le
pied on peut faire un mawashi Jordan au
visage il y a pas de
problème les casses de planche ça permet
de
départager le le combat s'il y a
égalité
au niveau national en tout cas à chaque
fois sauf cette année je sais pas quel
problème il y a eu mais les deux autres
années où j'y é t mooin et ben on a eu
de la casse à faire donc c'est une
épreuve qui qui s'inclut automatiquement
à la compétition est-ce que vous vous
entraîz régulièrement à casser des
planches régulièrement peut-être pas
parce que c'est vrai que il faudrait un
budget assez spécial pour pour l'achat
des planches mais à chaque compétition
une semaine VO de semaine avant on
commence à faire un peu de casse bon
c'est vrai qu'il serait préférable
d'intégrer aux entraînements les casses
mais comme comme je vous dis il faudrait
un budget en plus pour l'achat des
planches pour le club ce sera pas
évident quoi
mais en fait il faudrait il faudrait
prévoir le budget pour les planches pour
avoir peut-être une meilleure réussite
en casse et ramener la coupe du du
meilleur
casseur est-ce que ça vous souvent
justement de vous déplacer hors du
département oui ben là pour le
championnat de France au mois de février
et là bientôt j'aurai le championnat
d'Europe et le championnat du monde qui
va se faire à Hongrie et Osaka au Japon
euh ben les objectifs pour les les
prochains championnats je dirais bon
aller sortir dans dans les quatre
premières dans les les les quatre
premières mais il faudra vraiment il
faudra bossir est-ce qu'il y a des
combattantes que vous appréhendez
particulièrement oh non non non pas du
tout au contraire j'ai eu même des
félicitations cette année parce que bon
c'est vrai que quelque part au niveau de
l'arbitrage ils m'ont ils ont on va dire
ils ont arrangé ça à leur manière quoi
pour faire gagner le la métropolitaine
mais il y a quelqu'un de la fédération
qui était venu et on m'a dit que j'étais
très bien sur sur le tatami j'étais zen
quoi j'ai vraiment j'avais une maîtrise
et on avavait pas compris pourquoi
pourquoi j'avais pas eu le combat parce
qu'on était à égalité on était à égalité
donc il y avait rien pour départager mis
à part la bal et elle faisait 7 kg de
plus que moi et normalement ça aurait dû
moi qui aurait dû enfin qui aurait dû
être première et eux ils ont décidé de
refaire le dernier combat et étant
égalité donc c'était les arbitres qui
devaient juger le le gagnant d'accord
donc en fait j'ai perdu comme ça moi
cette année j'ai perdu parce que j'étais
à égalité
et mon adversaire elle a gagné si vous
voulez par décision
d'arbitre et quel est votre rythme
d'entraînement euh en fait ben comme je
pratique les deux toujours donc
c'est
de 2h environ 1h30 1h30 de chuteau camp
1h de de 1h30 voir 2h de de kukinkai en
entraînement normal pas en compétition
parce qu'en compétition ça va 3 à 4 He 3
à 4 heur par semaine par jour par jour
ça arrive que j'ai 2h 4 he par jour 2h
le matin 2h le soir tout dépend aussi de
l'organisation de grand
pierre quelle est la plus grosse
difficulté pour vous justement
l'organisation avec ma vie familiale oui
c'est très dur en fait faut dire que
j'ai j'ai un super mari ça je peux
pasier j'ai un super mari il est très
compréhensif il m'ide beaucoup il suit
aussi de temps en temps mes mes
déplacement au niveau au niveau
département et bon il m il m beaucoup
quoi tout ce qui est vie familiale enfin
tout ce qui est tout ce qui touche à la
vie de famille quoi parce que sinon je
peux pas je peux pas m'en
sortir déjà la Réunion ça aurait été
bien s'il y aurait eu plus de de
combattantes parce que bon de
combattants il y en a je veux dire des
des des hommes qui font qui font des
combats il y en a mais il manquerait en
fait des femmes qui se lancent dans la
compétition il y en a qui pratiquent
mais en fait c'est le contact au chos
qui Fa peut-être pas au chos déjà déjà
le châuteau quand même il y en a qui le
fait de dire que ça soit combat c'est ça
les freine quoi ils ont elles ont peur
donc ça aurait été bien qu'elle qu'ell
se lance pour qu'il y ait un peu plus
justement de de combattante c'est à
travers les combats qu'on évolue donc si
si c'est vrai dans d'une compétition
s'il y a que quatre filles donc je ferai
quoi trois quatre combats sauf s'il y a
des prolongations c'est pas suffisant
pour progresser je m'entraîne la plupart
du temps avec des garçons parce que bon
un manque de de filles moi je m'entraîne
avec des garçons il y en a aussi mais je
veux dire bon elles sont généralement
beaucoup plus petites beaucoup moins
buste donc ça fait pour avoir une
certaine force donc et puis le problème
c'est avec moi quand je m'entraîne avec
des filles je freine beaucoup mes coups
de peur de leur faire mal justement
parce que en fait j'appréhende je me dis
si je lance trop fort elles vont avoir
mal elles vont plus pouvoir faire donc
en fait je freine mes coups avec les les
femmes et je je dirais entre guillemets
je me défoule avec les hommes d'accord
et donc les hommes ils comprennent pas
alors ils me disent
ouais mais tu tapes dur toi
qu'est-ce que ça vous apporte qu'est-ce
que ça m'apporte bon
déjà avant tout c'est un sport
d'entretien d'accord c'est vrai déjà
donc ça permet de de m'entretenir et
puis au fil des années ben j'ai appris à
aimer et puis ça m'a poussé la
compétition mais il faut dire que c'est
un sport qui permet de se maîtriser ça
c'est sûr parce qu'on a tellement on on
canalise tellement d'énergie qu'à
certain moment on a on se sent obligé de
se libéré et donc c'est peut-être pour
ça que j'ai que j'aime ce style là aussi
hein et c'est préférable de se libérer
sur le tatami ah oui c'est sûr c'est sûr
oui c'est sûr bon ce le tatami déjà on
risque pas d'avoir des des problèmes à
l'extérieur et donc si puis j'apporte le
fait de voir déjà une femme faire du
karaté surtout le style que je fais je
pense que ça ça donne des idées aux
autres je je aux autres femmes quoi 2 3
je prépare actuellement le le le DIF
donc le diplôme instructeur fédéral
également le le brevet d'état pour être
professeur de karaté vous avez déjà des
contacts avec les enfants oui ben j'ai
commencé déjà mes mes stages donc ça se
déroule très bien et en fait il faut il
faut aimer quoi il faut aimer les
enfants il faut il faut avoir une
certaine comment dirais-je une certaine
facilité à à communiquer déjà avec les
gamins parce que c'est pas évident et en
fait ils prennent ça au jeu quoi c'est
ça en fait c'est transmettre son savoir
par l'intermédiaire des jeux c'est
surtout ça avec les gamins vous êtes le
leader féminin en coco Shinkai et chez
les garçon chez les garçons il y a
Jean-Luc vabodagom qui m'a toujours
accompagné enfin accompagné il a été mon
sparing il est toujours mon sparing il
m'aide beaucoup il il corrige mes
techniques il m'apprend beaucoup de
choses donc quand j'ai commencé le
karaté avec rond pierre il y a 12 ans de
cela il était là donc il m'a aidé à
préparer ma ceinture noire il m'a aidé à
à progresser dans les combats il m'a
apporté beaucoup de de techniques et
jusqu'aujourd'hui il y est pour quelque
chose
aussi comment vous arrivez justement à
vous préparer
mentalement comment je me prépare
mentalement avant un combat je dirais
c'est né chez moi depuis éant depuis
étant enfant en fait j'ai toujours
eu ta violent avec enfin violent entre
guillemets avec avec les autres j'ai
jamais eu peur des coups d'accord je
n'ai jamais eu peur des coup donc c'est
peut-être pour ça que je me suis dirigée
vers ce style de de de karaté mais
j'aime ça j'aime ce que je fais c'est
j'aime ça
quoi